soixante solution face au changement
climatique une exposition qui fait le
tour du monde
c'est à la bibliothèque départementale
de la réunion que les photographies de
yann arthus-bertrand continuent leur
tournée à travers 21 une photo l'agencé
française de développement et la
fondation goodplanet met en lumière des
solutions concrètes dans la lutte contre
le changement climatique
cette exposition est issu d'un livre qui
a été publiée par la fondation
goodplanet la fondation présidée par
yann arthus bertrand et c'est un livre
qui montrent que le réchauffement
climatique n'est pas qu'un problème mais
qu'il y a des solutions pour lutter et
accompagner le réchauffement climatique
et ses images ses photos qui sont prises
par yann arthus-bertrand sont également
illustrés de projets qui nous présente
des solutions parfois innovantes
solutions d'accompagnement d'adaptation
des populations des environnements des
écosystèmes au réchauffement climatique
nous sommes présents dans les outre mer
et dans 71 pays étrangers et nous
présentons cette exposition dans le
cadre de
comme 21 qui va se réunir très
prochainement et qui doit aboutir un
accord contraignant pour les états de
façon à réduire leurs effets de serre
les gaz pardon à effet de serre et
lutter ainsi contre le réchauffement
climatique
un public conquis par les 21 clichés
aériens de yann arthus-bertrand grand
photographe engagé une exposition qui
suscite chez chacun a envie d'agir
concrètement
mais pour l'instant c'est intéressant de
façon yann arthus bertrand c'est un
c'est vraiment le maître de la
photographie photographies aériennes en
particulier et je pense que c'est bien
de faire un lien entre ces photos et un
tel est le thème
de ce soir justement la préservation de
la planète et c'est intéressant ça déjà
un brin bandai partners je sais que dans
les écoles on va publier
on utilise souvent les supports de yann
arthus bertrand pour sensibiliser les
enfants à l'environnement en lien avec
cette exposition la bdr et la direction
de l'environnement du département mis en
place des ateliers pour les scolaires
durant une semaine les jeunes ont été
sensibilisés au thème du changement
climatique
en fait la médiation pour le public
scolaire
le thème c'est le changement climatique
puisque ce dernier comme un des sujets
que la direction de l'environnement
études y aborde est donc maintenant on
est là pour partager avec ses différents
savoirs au début on est entré on a fait
quatre expériences scientifiques
la première ça consistait avec des
glaçons de l'eau un bocal ensuite la
deuxième ça constitué à l'effet de serre
la troisième on faisait une expérience
avec sûr avec du coca cola et ensuite on
me laissait
avec une lumière une qui était couverte
une qui tue pas convertir
on a vu là qu'elle était la plus chaude
ensuite on a fait une petite question
n'a jamais d'informations sûres
l'exposition sera visible à la
bibliothèque départementale de la
réunion jusqu'au 16 octobre 2015